Speaker 1: And speaking of elections, let's
take a look at what's happening in Arizona.
Right.
There have been all kinds of revelations from
the state of Arizona this week with the ongoing
ballot audit that began in April.
Now in its fifth month, everything is a total
secret.
But earlier this week, actually, on Monday,
a magistrate judge in Arizona said, hey, Republicans
actually care and fan Arizona Republican Senate
president, you have to turn over all of the
documents, all of the communications that
you have about this ongoing ballot audit to
the groups who have sued, one of them being
the media at Arizona Republic.
They have a right to have this information.
And now you have Senate Republicans desperately
fighting and openly defying this court order
to turn over their communications about the
ballot audit.
Here's what they're looking for, quote, any
and all records with a substantial nexus to
the audit our public records.
The judge says this includes all communications
related to planning, the audit policies and
procedures of the audit and all records disclosing
who is paying for the audit and how much is
being spent.
That seems pretty innocuous to me, right?
I mean, we're not talking about turning over
the government's files on Area 51 folks, we're
talking about, hey, how is this being paid
for and how come up with a plan and what's
going on with it?
That's it.
That's literally what these groups are wanting
to find out and the judge says this stuff
should be public record.
It's supposed to be public record.
You got to release it.
And fans says, no, I'm not going to do it.
This is private.
This, I guess, is personal.
This entire audit from the start, as I'm sure
everyone watching this understands, this has
been a farce.
It is absolute political theater, you have
had Republicans from other states come in,
tour the facility where they were initially
doing the ballot on it so they could take
the blueprints essentially back to their own
states.
We also know that cyber ninja's, the group
conducting the audit, basically broke the
voting machines, now costing the voters in
Arizona three million dollars because, oops,
cyber ninjas accidentally got a bunch of malware
installed in the voting machines.
I'm sorry.
This is a terrible, terrible threat to our
democracy.
But it's also kind of hilarious that how incompetent
these individuals are.
And now, of course, cyber ninjas wants to
get their hands on the routers as if that's
really going to tell them much of anything.
Cybersecurity experts agree that the routers
really are going to be you know, you're not
going to get anything on that.
You would have had to have done it at the
time.
You know, after the fact, you're you're not
going to have any data stored there, most
likely.
So if you wanted that, you should have done
it as things were happening.
So you could have done the captures which
didn't happen.
So there's that then, of course.
And this is all, by the way, in the span of
just two weeks, a lot of it happening this
week.
So you've got the Republicans fighting to
keep everything secret.
They don't want anybody to know what's happening.
And, gee, I wonder why that is.
And then you also have Republicans subpoenaed,
both Dominion voting systems and Maricopa
County officials wanting even more information
to hand over to cyber ninjas.
And the Maricopa County folks said, listen,
the stuff you were asking us for, we can't
turn it over one because we don't even have
it.
It's not our stuff.
You're asking for something that other other
state entities have.
So we can't even do it.
But to if we did have it, we still wouldn't
do it.
Because what you're asking for includes Social
Security numbers of our voters.
You know, all of this vital private information
that, if leaked, could absolutely result in
a living nightmare for these individuals.
So, yeah, we don't have it, so we can't give
it to you.
But if we did have it, we wouldn't give it
to you.
We're not complying with this subpoena.
We've complied with everything else.
You have everything you need from us go away
at this point is basically what they're saying.
And Dominion, you know, came back with similar
things.
We've given you everything Dominion says.
Anything else you ask for at this point is
ridiculous.
Just like, by the way, this entire ballot
audit is, folks.
I have no doubt, and I have said this plenty
of times over on my YouTube channel, that
fair and balanced and it ring of fire.
If they had found anything at all.
Anything.
A single instance of fraud, they would be
coming out holding a press conference saying,
ladies and gentlemen, the investigation is
ongoing, but I want to highlight this this
case of fraud here that we found that had
gone unnoticed.
This is why the ballot, they haven't done
that because they have nothing to do that
for.
You also, by the way, a member of the Senate
appointed audit team, the leader of it, came
out and said, oh, we found 74000 ballots.
Mail out ballots that we have no record of
sending out and then reporters actually looked
at the record and immediately said, actually,
there is a record of all of these going out.
You're straight up lying to us now.
So they're openly lying.
They're hiding the information.
And there's no signs of this thing going away
any time soon.
It's been going on for five months and apparently
it is just going to keep
on rolling.